so you you had a good career as a lawyer  I mean until I didn't right I mean so  were you married yes  do you have kids no okay so you're  married had a good career I had dogs  that were kids yeah yeah  and then what happened  I mean  yeah I mean you're living on the streets  now  right  um I do live in the streets now  it's especially not like  I don't admit it but like it hasn't been  something that has been like  thrust upon me in a way that like I feel  like I don't have I could I can't get  out of it it sounds like an extreme  change though for your lifestyle right  yes but it's also one that like like  became  like an alternative to being with my  family